the movie opens in New York City with
the introduction of several characters
at once the first one is a security
guard named Muhammad who is looking at a
heartfelt homemade greeting card another
one is a charismatic comedian named
George who is getting ready for an
upcoming event while effortlessly
practicing his jokes next is a poised
television reporter named Maureen and
her fiance Don who are currently having
a private time in their lavish Mansion
the other characters are a beautiful and
pregnant woman named Celine an elderly
Widow named Jane an obese guy named
Martin and lastly there is an esteemed
businessman named Henry Barton and his
spoiled ten-year-old granddaughter
Madeline all of them are on their way to
a 52-story skyscraper which is owned by
none other than Henry in the next scene
all the aforementioned characters arrive
at Henry's skyscraper for an event
happening on the building's uppermost
floor one after another they all step
into the same elevator after passing
through security checks George appears
to be claustrophobic so he asks this
security guard not to overload the lift
regardless the security guard fills the
elevator with all nine people which is
the maximum limit as the elevator
ascends George becomes restless his
Focus remains fixed on the ascending
floor numbers Martin tries to comfort
him saying that he has been using the
lift since six years ago and it has
never caused any problems quick dick
knock on what oh there's no wood you're
all boned in order to intensify the
situation for George the mischievous
Madeline presses the emergency stop
button causing the elevator to stop
abruptly as a result Georgia loses it
and starts scolding the young girl Henry
steps in to defend his granddaughter
saying that it was an accident but
George knows that she did it on purpose
fortunately before the situation gets
out of hand Muhammad manages to calm
everyone down he then advises Henry to
press the restart button which he does
however to everyone's surprise the
elevator does not move panicked Henry
presses the button for the lobby floor
resulting in a slight descent before
another halt at this point Point
George's claustrophobia escalates into
full-blown panic so he begins chastising
Madeleine using swear words this enrages
Henry prompting him to fire George from
his comedian role however this does not
affect George because he just wants to
get out of this elevator when the
elevator does not move Henry presses the
intercom button and alerts security
about it after learning of the problem
the security says that he will dispatch
a maintenance crew as they wait for the
assistance the group starts to talk to
each other fostering a sense of
connection amongst them Henry says that
he's about to retire from his position
and live a peaceful life from now on he
just wants to find a capable successor
as soon as possible after a while the
pregnant lady Celine feels an urgent
need to use the bathroom unable to hold
on any longer she decides to use her bag
as an improvised toilet the rest of the
people turn away while Martin generously
uses his coat to ensure privacy in the
midst of this Madeline takes a look and
makes a rude remark but her grandfather
shuts her up gen Alpha will never learn
respect and the world will die
I'm sorry but I'm not sorry the
conversation then shifts to Jane who
shares her heartbreaking story with
everyone she reveals that her son died
in Iraq last year and her husband
committed the unthinkable after
suffering a huge financial loss he had
actually bought some shares from Henry's
company but the value declined rapidly
in a matter of weeks Jane tearfully says
that she and her husband had planned to
buy a boat in order to enjoy their
retirement days but their dream was
never fulfilled she spills her rage on
Henry indirectly accusing him for her
loss in response Henry says that life
can be unfair sometimes so it's best to
live each day like it's the last he then
inquires why Jane is here now before she
can answer his question Jane suddenly
begins to struggle for air seemingly
having a heart attack she slowly
collapses to the floor and in her final
breath she reveals that she has a bomb
which explains that she is here to exact
Vengeance for her husband the Revelation
sends everyone into a state of panic and
Martin immediately calls 9-1-1 and
informs them about the ongoing situation
not long after Jane passes away and
Muhammad who once worked as a medic
her death after this the reporter
Maureen starts filming and streaming the
events using her phone Henry one more
time tries to contact the security via
the elevator radio but he is rudely told
to have patience amidst all this the
trapped individuals engage in an
argument about who should step forward
to inspect Jane's body to check for the
presence of a bomb after arguing for a
while Celine volunteers for the task at
first she cautiously checks Jane's bag
but finds nothing but a wallet prompting
all of them to breathe a sigh of relief
however they do find a news clipping
from her purse that contains the
information about her husband's death
case Celine then proceeds to check
Jane's body and this time she finds
something in her stomach upon
unbuttoning the clothes she discovers
the bomb secured around her waist by
means of a bike lock the Revelation
frightens everyone and they fall silent
for a while meanwhile the reporter
Maureen who has documented everything
transfers the footage to her television
station after being left without
assistance for an extend ended period
the trapped group tries to find an
alternative means of escape from the
elevator Don takes the initiative he
ascends to the ceiling and attempts to
break through a panel in hopes of
uncovering an escape hatch but to their
bad luck he only finds the lights up
there after all the failed attempts
Celine lights up a cigarette in order to
calm herself down but Dawn stops her
from smoking citing the potential harm
to her unborn child also you know the
bomb Celine then reacts with a surge of
anger asking if he wants to be a
responsible father now this Outburst
catches Maureen's attention and she
suspects that her fiance was having an
affair with the woman when she asks Don
about it he hesitantly reveals that he
and Celine were indeed having an affair
in the past what's more he also
acknowledges the possibility of being
the father of celine's unborn child this
shocking confession leaves Maureen in a
state of emotional turmoil in the
outside world the video footage recorded
by Maureen picks up the story which is
broadcast as breaking news all over the
nation the bomb acre who is responsible
for making the explosive device for Jane
also sees the broadcast after which he
looks very worried and guilty meanwhile
the trapped group opens the door in a
forceful manner in order to check if
there is any way out upon doing so they
see a small opening above and Dawn
attempts to climb out however his effort
turns out to be futile as the opening is
too small following this he uses Jane's
cane and stretches his hand to the
fullest in hopes of reaching the
elevator button outside he is about to
reach the button but at the same time
Madeline rapidly presses several buttons
on the control panel from inside as a
consequence the elevator's brakes
disengage sending the elevator
plummeting several floors the violent
descent severs Dawn's arm and the cabin
goes completely dark at this point I say
strap the bomb to Madeline and throw her
through the little hole upon restoration
of power a gruesome sight becomes
apparent Dawn's arm is torn off and
Henry's forehead is cut with a deep
wound also it appears Madeline's head is
disappeared up her own ass reacting
swiftly Muhammad employs a necktie as a
makeshift tourniquet to slow down the
blood loss from Dawn's severed arm
elsewhere the man who crafted the bomb
is weighed down by guilt for endangering
the lives of eight people so he reaches
out to Media reporters in order to
confess his wrong Deeds when asked by
the Press he explains his motivations
behind creating the bomb for Jane he
reveals a deep personal connection
explaining that Jane's deceased son was
a close friend of his so he felt a sense
of indebtedness towards their family in
addition he discloses that the bomb
contains highly lethal explosive
components and estimates that it is set
to detonate within the next 10 minutes
the trapped group watches this
confession unfold on Martin's mobile
phone and begins to lose hope of living
however George suggests opening the door
one more time considering the
possibility that the recent elevators
movement might have created an opening
Beyond the Door the group rallies behind
his suggestion and with United effort
they managed to pry the door open
however to their dismay they find no
pathway behind it George is still not
ready to give up so he contemplates
opening the elevator again he claims
that there might be enough space for
them to throw the bomb down the shaft or
perhaps Madeline averting the potential
catastrophe however the situation is not
as easy as it looks because the bomb is
Chained into Jane's body George then
asks if anyone has anything sharp to
which Muhammad hands him a tiny knife
since the metal chain can't be cut He
suggests dismembering Jane's body and
separating her from the bomb considering
it as their last resort everybody agrees
however when it is time to act George is
unable to muster enough courage for such
a grim task witnessing his hesitation
Henry steps forward taking over the
responsibility due to his past
experience in animal Butchery after
taking a deep breath he begins cutting
into Jane's body as Henry proceeds he
reaches her abdominal region body needs
some assistance in removing her organs
so Muhammad and George help him with the
bloody operation when they are still
unable to cut through her spine they opt
to snap it the group then divides their
forces and twists the body pulling from
opposite ends in the midst of this
George considers Henry to be responsible
for all of this so he tells him to hand
over one million dollars to each of them
if they survive surprisingly Henry
agrees oh damn says George make it three
just then a security guard communicates
via the intercom delivering the
long-awaited news that the rescue and
bomb squads have finally arrived he
assures them that the team will get all
of them out soon within moments the
rescue team lowers the elevator and
prize open the door creating a narrow
passage to extricate the trapped group
then they begin to pull everyone up one
after another when only Martin is left
he knows that the opening is not big
enough for him to fit through George on
the other hand desperately orders the
rescue members to lower the elevator to
another floor in order to rescue Martin
however since only a few minutes are
left on the clock they reluctantly close
the elevator door leaving Martin stuck
inside with Jane's corpse poor guy weeps
uncontrollably knowing his death is
imminent but in his final moments he
regains his composure and realizes he is
the hero as he helped everybody survive
with this realization he waits for the
inevitable and the bomb detonates within
a few seconds in the aftermath of this
tragic event Dawn is urgently
transported to the hospital while George
and Muhammad sit together their
expressions reflecting a mix of
desolation and relief as Henry passes by
George reminds him of the pledged one
million dollars for each Survivor but
the latter brushes it off George and
Muhammad then share a brief conversation
contemplating the uncertain Road of life
ahead shortly after a news reporter
approaches George and questions him
about how he managed to stay so brave
during such an ordeal George chooses to
hide the truth stating that he needed to
stay composed for the well-being of
everyone involved moments later he
receives a call from his wife who has no
idea about this entire incident she
reminded him to pick up groceries on his
way home George also does not disclose
anything to her and simply agrees before
walking away subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching